they do all the hard work I think we're
live now sick
are we also like live on uh on like
YouTube or something yeah oh sick right
on
um
there's like a stop sign above you not
like a stop but like uh a square yeah
that means stop okay so
just in case you want to know I don't
know how to get rid of that right now
should I figure it out I can figure it
out what do you mean a stop like a like
this
you see that
oh yeah I don't know what the [__] that
is is that always there though can they
see that I don't think they can see that
I think
I think it's still there
uh uh yeah there's a yeah it's still
there
uh maybe this will help
I know I'm not too worried about it
okay yeah I know
yeah
okay
it's just like
it was like my I just built that myself
so it's like very haphazard hey dude
you're doing a [__] great job though
thank you dude to have a full [__]
podcast studio in your place is awesome
I know it's so convenient yeah [__] yeah
it saves so much time because otherwise
it'd be like I have to go and actually
be more responsible than I actually am
and when you have to like book at the
time at a place and you have to use
other people's [__] and maybe someone
like they're running behind like now
you're just on your schedule all the
[__] time that's right I know I love
how we did this podcast because we did
it like in the way that it was perfect
time for both of us hopefully yeah oh
yeah yeah I know it was good when you
were like you just hit me up more like
can you do it now and I was like not
right now I can do it in like an hour is
that good yeah I wrote
I jerked off a little bit dude sick you
out of jerk off in today I haven't got a
jerk multiple jerk offs because you're
traveling it's harder to jerk it it is
harder to jerk it when you're traveling
and I'm sharing an Airbnb we both have
separate rooms but it's like you like
jerking off in like a house when there's
no one's there that's the [__] the
greatest the ultimate sneak tip you know
the low down jerk what do you jerk off
do today uh uh what I came to the most
recently is like a girl in her panties
just like doing panty porn oh what kind
of like just like playing with her
panties like but the panties are some
dudes was uh she had it on and you know
it's just like the classic panties look
and he's like jerking off into the
panties no he's just touching and
spinning around and looking at it oh so
it's very that's very soft core right
now yeah well sometimes you never know
you know after having been down all
these rugged roads you know sometimes
what gets you is like a little Canary
floating on your little beard that's
true dude you never like you watch so
much perverted [__] just the the you're
watching like a dp anal penetration then
you're like you know what I just need a
nice pretty lady and some silk yeah
that's all that I would have taken to
get you off dude the kissing sometimes
really gets me when I just see them kiss
yeah because I'm like oh it's like it's
more intimate yeah like there's more of
a connection rather than just some
chick's face getting [__] like crazy
although I did look up some classic uh
Sasha Gray with her just getting like
throw [__] like intensely
um and it was uh it was great
yeah I mean that's the next level uh if
you get all the basics done you want to
move on to the next thing you don't want
to just be stuck on kissing forever no
my buddy calls it sexual inflation which
he's he says you got to manage it or you
can't get too deep into it because like
once you start liking something and
you're jerking off to it you're [__]
a certain way and you need that to come
then you've reached like a new level and
then you keep if you keep going higher
and higher and higher you just need like
continuously more [__] up things to
come it's more and more divorced from
reality exactly yeah so it's like every
now and again you need like silk panties
just to bring you back down they were at
silk
normal cotton panties
um but yeah I agree with that I think
it's important to be grounded
I mean I have a new sexual partner now
and I'm just sort of just
going ham on the the porn and the
jerking off was you because you have a
new sexual partner
in spite of that oh in spite of like I
know it would probably help but I think
like I gotta learn how to be in a
relationship while also jerking off as
much as I want damn yeah so you're like
going You're Going In The Deep End right
away yeah so are you guys exclusive yeah
oh okay so you've been [__] for a
while
of three months okay so three months and
now you're like we're going exclusive
and now you're like I'm introducing porn
you're evolving what this whole
relationship means to you yeah I'm
evolving by devolving Yeah by going back
into porn I'm gonna do this thing where
I watch porn and have a girlfriend at
the same time it's revolutionary stuff
how long have you been doing this for uh
like three months now okay
well no three months you've been seeing
her for three months yeah but how long
you've been doing and the porn in her
this whole three months oh so the
point's been there they never stopped so
nothing's changed yes I'm just gonna
keep doing what I'm doing even though
it's
you know sometimes it's hard for me to
get hard you know they have to swear I
think that's the biggest problem yeah I
know and it's like totally my fault it's
like yeah I don't need to figure it out
I like the self-awareness though you're
self-aware that you're like yo I am uh
if I stopped watching porn I would have
a better sex life with this girl but
porn is so [__] good and also I'm not
gonna stop watching porn so it's I'm
just gonna have to endure I'm gonna have
to find a way to have sex that will
compliment my porn watching and then
I'll have both you can watch porn with
her as you [__] Yeah ideally or you
could
um you are you just start like using
Viagra and then go even deeper in the
hole like use Viagra to [__] even your
girlfriend and then you can be like one
of those porn stars that can like only
get hard with Viagra if you heard that
pin thing that they do no they have this
thing where they'll stick like a pin in
their dick and it hits like a nerve or a
certain thing that like forces you to
get an erection like a cow yeah yeah
wait do they do the cows yeah they uh
stick a metal rod up their ass and they
electrocute them and they come oh really
yeah did not
that's how they like extract semen from
them yeah oh [__] so they can just like
milk the [__] cat so like that and
you force the humans but for humans and
dudes do this themselves all the time in
the porn industry uh yeah it sounds like
there's a point of like it's like uh
it's gonna take a toll on you oh yeah I
think being a porn star isn't all like
you think of uh like from the dude
perspective you'd be like I'm just gonna
be [__] all these girls it's great
but it's like grueling on your body
physically it's like a lot of physical
it's like every other work that we have
it's gonna become uberified and you're
gonna have to like get an app to do it
yes exactly I have no health care and
it's gonna be like Ai and you're easily
replaced and then you're gonna yeah no
Health Care there's gonna be no safety
net no pension uh and then you're gonna
want to like protest but then they're
gonna fire you and You're Gonna Wanna
unionize it's gonna get [__] yeah yeah
especially for
yeah I feel like girls might have it
rough because they get a lot of stuff
done to them and then they it was like
500 bucks yeah like how much is that
worth I think uh but the girls make I
think a lot more money than the dudes
unless you're doing gay stuff dudes
doing gay stuff make like crazy money
that's like where the cash is nice yeah
it's not a big audience but they do buy
a lot of stuff yeah yeah
laughs
um but yeah I mean I
uh I I like the idea of that thing in
your dick that you hit to get a boner
um I don't think I'm there yet I think I
can just do it it's like I don't want to
be like having sex with a person and
thinking about something else yeah when
I could just be in that moment it just
seems unnecessary and inefficient hey
sometimes it's hard to get into the
moment though because sometimes you like
you you aren't in it or you're not
turned on or you're [__] them for
them or like I don't know you're you're
like when you're on the road and stuff
and you're like like you're exclusive
with someone now but there was probably
a time when you were like [__] a
bunch of like strangers like constantly
yeah and like that I I've gone to a
point where sometimes that feels like a
little bit numb like I'm like am I
losing my spark yeah I used to love to
do this I know it's like like seems like
uninteresting yeah because then you're
just uh having sex with like a body
instead of who they are as a person yeah
you know I've been like really thinking
about them you're thinking about some
other person you [__] or some video
you watched and then you're almost just
like yeah it's just like another day in
the office but you're [__] someone
yeah hopefully you're like interested
enough in that that process of just
you know being with someone and it's
it's new to you like when was it like
the perfect sweet spot
I think it was like the first
the I think even before like I was doing
all the Social Media stuff and that
started popping and pulling in fans I
think it was when
um I started Living on my own for the
first time and I was like I had my own
space and I could have girls kind of
come over whenever or when I first first
started getting popular on Tick Tock
that was like when it felt [__] cool
when there was like girls would just
come like straight like you wouldn't
even meet me before they would just be
like hey can I come over and they would
just come over to the place and we'd
[__] and then they would go after that
was like I was like this is so then you
were in the moment you were thinking
like oh this person just came from
ticktalk.com yeah and you're just like
totally on board with the whole
experience now it's like oh this is like
a tick tock slot I have to go to a thing
at 30 p.m the ice creams in the fridge
yeah exactly like I it was it was like
this past weekend I there was I hooked
up with I hooked up with five different
people this past weekend yeah and most
of it was really good but there was a a
couple where I was like really out of it
and I felt like I was just doing it to
do it and I was like oh man I was like
maybe I shouldn't have done it maybe I
should have just gone to sleep instead
and I got a bad night's sleep because of
it and that's what I'm thinking about
like in the moment I'm like what time is
it I got a [__] to do in the morning
like I'm gonna get a shitty sleep and
then I'm gonna be tired tomorrow and and
I was like what is going on like this
used to be the most fun thing you could
do and now it's like I wouldn't say it
feels like a chore but it felt it didn't
feel as exciting wow yeah yeah no I
think that's that's good like if you
were just into that all the time then
that would take up your whole life I'm
guessing yeah yeah it would be become
debilitating like some sort of addiction
or something yeah so you don't have that
particular thing where it's like oh you
just can full yourself up totally with
just that yeah I feel like I do do you
at all feel like you have a problem with
like consumption or anything like that
um what like porn or ice cream porn
drugs booze food oh you just I'm just
like consuming things to feel better
about myself uh be feel better about
yourself or just like a dopamine
pleasure like the constant need
I maybe with marijuana yeah but not
really no no I I definitely feel like
I'm constantly keeping like the beast at
Bay whatever it is it's like oh eat a
bag of chips eat some carbs [__] this
girl go jerk off do these drugs have a
drink like just do comedy do comedy at
least comedy I'm like oh I have to do
this now this is my job
um but it is sort of the same thing it's
just a more healthy outlet for it it is
it is very much the same thing like a
kill like when you really get like the
when you destroy and you have all the
people come up to after and then you go
on the road and you're doing these
things and your career is growing it
gives you like a huge sense of like uh
yeah of like a high and I think that's
the same people love like reason people
of sales like sales is the same kind of
thing every time you get sales you get
like a cell when you're doing sales yeah
you [__] get a huge high off of it
yeah and then you grow addicted and then
you start telling yourself I'm the best
salesman I could sell
uh something that a lot of people have
in a place where they have a lot of it
yeah and then you [__] bomb
yeah and then you don't get it and then
you fail and then you feel like you have
a small dick and you have to hurt
someone
laughs
I like the immediate response is
violence I understand the inferiority
but the violence I don't know maybe
sometimes that's just the thing you have
to look out for yeah whenever I feel any
strong emotion I'm like how does this
turn to violence yeah true that is true
because it can't devolve into violence
and that's the one thing that you can do
that other people will [__] with you
with yeah yeah like if you're just
hurting yourself that no one cares but
once you start threatening to hurt other
people like that guy on the subway
which guy in the Subway on the New York
yeah oh yes kidding that [__] was
[__] crazy did you see the video I I
saw I just saw a picture yeah and it but
like I I mean I haven't been in New York
back uh like I left in New York uh on
Thursday so I've been gone the entire
time of all these protests and
everything like that
um but yeah they were like what happened
like At first they're like oh yeah [__]
that guy but then they're like wait wait
a minute like it took a while for people
to be like this is [__] up it was it's
[__] up in like the because it's like
a guy a homeless guy coming out of the
subway in New York and being like Oh I
need money I'm broke that's every single
[__] day so I I don't know I haven't
seen what led up to them like trying to
restrain this dude or what why this dude
like choked him to death but it's like
[__] and the chill guy to death you
got to choke him for a long [__] time
man yeah like you like we uh you know
you watch MMA guys get choked
unconscious all the time and they get
choked unconsciously and then you let go
he had to like continuously choke him
after he was unconscious yeah for him to
die
yeah I mean I don't know I don't like uh
[__] with people's necks yeah no I
have like a fragile neck myself but yeah
I mean you don't want to [__] especially
if you're homeless you got whatever
health issues you haven't been eating
yeah absolutely your body's barely
hanging on as it is you don't touch the
neck keep keep your hands free of the
neck yeah yeah I yeah it's just like
it's just like uh I don't think people
are doing this in Finland I don't think
people in Finland are going out
murdering each other in the subway no I
I wonder my whole thing with it is like
is it just like a population issue
because you have a lot of these
countries that have like better prison
systems better uh Healthcare better uh
like uh pay systems like uh pensions all
these things is it just because America
has so many [__] people they can't
afford to give these people things or is
it just this like the huge focus on
capitalism first that has like forced
everyone into poverty well I think it's
like a slavery outline yeah we got the
plantation owners and all of us are the
slaves and that was just that was the
outline from the beginning and that's
how the outline has always been yeah so
we don't care about each other yeah
especially with the whole you know
African-American population you're
allowed to just like punish and torture
your own citizens yeah yeah yeah like in
uh [__] Japan at some point you're
like well they're Japanese too there's
like a limit to that and like uh Sweden
you know they're like we're all Swedish
yeah but here it's just like [__] them
so they dehumanize the people because
they feel they don't feel like they have
a connection to them yeah because there
is like a wild level of that here and it
doesn't seem like a to acquire the
things that a lot of these other places
have like uh like yeah proper Healthcare
uh uh uh proper pension plans uh
affordable living all these things that
help like secure your society and help
people be like less violent uh less
addicted to drugs uh safer they are ex
should be accessible in America but
every time people try to push those
agendas forward they end up dying or
like like move these movements stop like
there was the like Martin Luther King
get shot well Malcolm X gets shot all
these people that try to make any sort
of change it all [__] falls apart
yeah it's like the [__] slave owners
I guess it's like a crude term but like
yeah I mean uh like the people that are
in charge whoever shot JFK you know they
they're like no we want to have this
Society where it's just a few on top and
everyone else on the bottom and we're
going to kill anyone to make that happen
exactly and I saw like I saw just a bit
of it like and I want to be very clear
on this side it was a little bit of a
tick tock so who knows how how truthful
this information is but someone on Tick
Tock was talking about how
um Africa is like the wealthiest country
in terms of resources has like the most
minerals most like things that we need
in the west and in a lot of other
countries and anytime a leader has moved
forward to try and uh turn that into
profit for the country itself they die
or go missing or something and it's like
totally how do you change the system I I
don't know it seems like anytime someone
really does try to change it like a JFK
or something yeah they'll just blow your
[__] head off yeah I think it's just
like numbers at this point there's so
many of us and only a certain number of
them yeah they can't keep holding off
this uh you know power disparity this
imbalance yeah like at some point we
find our our level this isn't
sustainable but yeah I mean I think it's
uh shitty and it's like they're holding
us hostage and holding civilization
hostage so that they can be on top and
it's it's not like people are asking for
a lot either people are just asking to
uh to be able to like I want a house to
live in like housing should be mandatory
for like a human right Healthcare human
right drinking water food human rights
like these internet human rights treat
us like an animal in a zoo it's like not
it's not that crazy it's not that crazy
but we're not asking to be like flying
on private jets every single [__] day
yeah and but the amount that these
people were consuming and the the
perception of like what's our
responsibility to like with the
pollution and all that stuff people like
oh you're not recycling it's like dude
you're polluting a thousand times my
lifetime every day like what the [__]
are you you're blaming this on me
um but uh but yeah it's uh
what the the answer is is I I've said I
think we need like a Genghis Khan type
figure like Genghis Khan like rallied
all the small tribes all the all the
people of the step against their one
common enemy because it was all you have
all these tribes are infighting you have
like black lives matter you have cops
you have feminists you have like [__]
uh in cells all these are like tribes
yeah and then they're all in fighting
with each other when there's one common
enemy that's that's suppressing them and
you need a central figure to put all
these tribes together to be like no no
we shouldn't be fighting each other we
should be fighting this one common enemy
so why do you think that figure hasn't
Arisen or do you think he has in the
form of Bernie Sanders and we just
[__] dnc'd his ass maybe that could
be it it could have been that he did
arise in the form of Bernie Sanders and
then it just didn't happen I uh like I
feel like there's uh or maybe he's still
coming or maybe he won't come and it'll
just crumble like a roam or something in
America will just like fall into poverty
well hopefully we don't need a person
hopefully we can just figure it out on
our own without like uh a cult figure
yeah that is true like you would hope
that people are able to
Rally themselves and not yeah not
Reliance it is nice to have some
guidance I don't have someone who's able
to point the way but that people can
come together and stop this like
infighting because there's so much
infighting and when you break it down
it's all economics like you you there's
like race relations all these things
it's always you go back to like kings
and queens it's always Rich versus poor
that's what it has always been and
that's what it will always will be and
that's the separation between us
actually right like Martin Luther King
when he got assassinated it wasn't him
doing like marches to make sure black
people could vote he went to go talk at
a factory about wage disparities between
black and white workers and how they
should all be paid the same once he
started talking about money that's when
he got killed
yeah I mean I agree with you uh yeah I
mean it's like money like oh black
people are black so we can pay them less
you know Mexican people we have a
different pay scale for them it's like
oh we're using race for economic gain
yeah
um yeah I just think like since it's
about money it should be easy to figure
out but they had like so many years of
ancient tradition withholding like uh
holding up this way of being like unfair
so it's like we have so much of it
ingrained in us I think the population
is really on board with it yeah and I
think there's they use like small little
tactics to make it seem like there's
some sort of difference between us like
abortion laws or whatever it is they'll
be like oh and then that divides the
people then we have the division between
the small tribes when we realize like
this one small issue there isn't some
sort of compromise we can find in
between it which I do think like the
state by state thing it can be some form
of a compromise to at least stop people
from fighting yeah with each other
although I'm definitely pro-choice on
all those things yeah I think uh it's
crazy that uh you know we're divided and
all that
um and economics yeah I think it's like
a lot of it is with money so yeah I mean
I don't know maybe I don't know
uh does your podcast normally get this
serious off the top yeah usually okay
the only one doing it right on awesome
um but yeah I uh I think it's crazy that
uh you know there's like just so many
greedy people like it's just like five
or seven of them it's insane it's insane
that it's like it's like when is it
enough how much do you need and it's
like to do some [__] like Jeff Bezos
going to space for like five minutes
like spending billions of dollars on
something like that it's like it's not
that that should be like illegal but
like should there be some sort of
Taxation on it that forces if you're
gonna spend frivolously on something
that
useless
that other people have to benefit
someone like a large group of people if
you're spending billions of dollars to
go to space then a large group of people
need a benefit off of billions of
dollars of worth of like clean drinking
water easy access to food Education
Centers things that make your
neighborhood safer and cleaner like I
don't I don't know and there's all these
things like the War on Drugs too that
that has been proven to like make uh
countries more dangerous you have places
like Portugal that have legalized all of
drugs and now they're a recovery rate
from addiction is like way higher than
any other country they have like a 55
success rate in addictions or something
in in Canada it's like three percent
yeah in recovery now I don't know if
someone is in chat and knows I'm
completely wrong you can [__] rip me
up in the comments or whatever the [__]
um but uh a lot of there's we see the
benefit in a lot of these things in
factual data like you've seen like
Universal basic income helps people be
go less hospital visits they're they
actually tend to work harder because
they're not worried about my new things
they're not doing like a shitty nine to
five that that just helps them scrape by
we know that legalizing drugs reduces
crime increases safety reduces
addictions helps people get off of drugs
all these things are better with our
weird the way our brains are wired to
seem counterintuitive but the facts are
there that show that they actually work
but we still don't do them based on of
people's reaction to it I think
uneducated reaction I think it's because
like they are not there to help us
they're there to keep the power
structure the economic structure the you
know the distribution of wealth the way
it is right now whatever that might be
so it's not to help like drug addicts
it's to you know make sure that there's
like a bottom so that people can fall
out so that uh you know like you know
too many of them aren't asking like how
can we make it better or whatever yeah
um but yeah I think that's why there's
so many shitty things in this uh
societies because we're not trying to
make it better we're trying to keep it
the same yeah whatever it takes no that
is very true there's like there's a lot
of opportunity for improvement and every
time people try to do it it's like swept
away or is hamstrung you look at things
like the automotive industry in America
and there should be like some sort of
train system like they have in Europe
that would make everything like better
but the plane system and the automotive
industry won't let that happen yeah it's
like they already got it figured out so
they're like let's not change it yeah
like we know how to make a ton of money
off of this and we have these systems by
the balls that's why I think one of my
buddies said uh we were talking about Ai
and you know how like Elon and a bunch
of these like Big Rich tech people said
a little while ago oh we need to put a
six-month hold on AI and then they
didn't obviously but my buddy was like
well they probably want to do that
because
um because they don't know how to profit
off of this yet if they knew how to make
money off of AI and they could Implement
all those systems already they'd be like
yeah we need to push this forward even
faster this is the future but they want
to put a hole in it so that they can
monopolize it and then other people
can't use it to get ahead yeah that's
their only interest is in preserving
their wealth yeah which is like [__]
what do you what do they what what is
the point what do they need it for what
is the what is it what it what is there
something I don't know is there
something that I don't know is the world
actually going to end and these people
are trying to preserve their blood
Bloodlines and like these secret pods or
something yeah it's some ancient [__]
mechanism it's like our desire to
procreate it's like an amoeba in us and
they accentuate it and it's like this is
a one part of the human experience that
we could accentuate and the people that
do will get risen to the top but that's
not healthy yeah it's just one way of
being that we reward for whatever reason
yeah idea I don't know I I I to me it
doesn't make any sense and I don't find
it to be very valuable to only chase the
dollar throughout like I mean like we're
both doing comedy I I never started
doing stand-up to chase the dollar I
started doing one I moved to Toronto I
was homeless at first I stayed in a
youth shelter for the first six months
so I could like go and do shows and
grind mics and start doing comedy wow
but I did it because it gave me like
purpose and something that I loved doing
and I could I like yeah that's all we
need yeah and so many people don't have
it we make sure they don't have it yeah
we're sure they do stupid [__] with
their life so they don't have any
purpose and they can't change anything
and it's like the like back on the
universal basic income thing it's like
how much could people accomplish if they
didn't have to spend their times doing
like the most boring menial like low
value things like someone who's like
running uh McDonald's not to [__] on a
person who's running a McDonald's but if
that's not what they love to do but
they're doing it because that gets them
by and they do it amazing what if
they're like there was that uh a patent
Oswald's wife who they caught the Golden
State killer through like mind shares of
people sharing information and all this
kind of stuff yeah they've tracked this
guy down something the police can never
do they found out who it was and they
they caught this guy could is in jail or
yeah he's in jail now he might have died
in jail he he was like old when they
finally caught him but what could people
accomplish right if they were free if
they were free all these things would be
like who knows what people would be
developing solving puzzles problems uh
yeah but that's why they don't do it is
because they don't want that they don't
want to solving [__] because once you
start solving [__] you fix what's around
you and that would ruin who's on top so
as soon as you get on top you just try
to keep yourself there it's like what
are they even doing up there man like
what are they even doing other than
trying to keep us down it's like we're
not trying to [__] ruin your lives
we're trying to make everyone's life
better it's just like they're not even
conscious beings almost they're like
part of it they're swept up in it
because if they're not Psychopathic then
someone else's and they're going to take
the position yeah and it's like it's
just a mountain of uh House of Cards
yeah yeah
well hopefully it tumbles down like yeah
I uh part of me thinks that the only way
that you could do it is like you gotta
just start chopping heads off you're
gonna like try some billionaire into the
street and chop his head off and like
another stream and it's so [__] up but
like with only a couple well-placed
bullets you could fix the world you
could do you do a real good job man yeah
it's like the heads of like
pharmaceutical companies and these
different things you're just like and
did it like publicly they'd be like
crazy yeah well I think we're doing it
in a less violent way right now through
like slowly changing people's minds and
being like hey this game is not worth
playing yeah yeah
so if if everyone in origin if 40 in our
generation 50 60 soon yeah is going to
turn it around hopefully fingers crossed
on that and that we can get to something
that's a little bit cleaner and safer
and
yeah so people everyone can just live
like there's no reason there should be
any homeless person in uh America
whether like even if they have a severe
psychological disorder and they have a
no family they should have access to
some sort of
um institution that takes care of them
because that is the only option there
needs to be Social Services on that
level yeah that that shouldn't be a
question all across America with the
amount of wealth that's a year
yeah we just don't want to take care of
ourselves and then we don't treat each
other very well and then we do mass
shootings yeah and I think that there is
that individualism that is ripe in
America that causes people to be
not as I don't know inclusive or not as
accepting or more scared of the outside
forces like the amount of not even just
the shoot the mass shootings but there
was like four shootings in a row where
like that Katie like knocked on
someone's door and like I shot him in
the face yeah it's like what the [__]
someone knocks on your door and you feel
like you need to shoot them that's
insane what is going on in your life
where you feel like you need to shoot us
just don't open the door have we thought
about that yeah he's like you know it
came on my property that now I got to do
whatever I want on here yeah and it's
like no this is It's a human being there
was a there was a guy I think I think it
was in Texas there was a guy who
um some dude uh tricked him he charged
him forty dollars for parking at a
restaurant and there was no charge for
the parking so sometimes the guy was
just scamming people he went out in his
car got a gun and then shot the guy and
killed him and then he was on a date and
then went back on the date like told the
girl like hey just wait here I'm just
gonna go check yeah it's like you're
honor is everything you got to protect
your reputation of someone cheats you
then you're going to murder them it's
like bro you you killed a person over 40
dollars and also it's like doesn't that
uh attest to like your insecurity or the
fragileness of your ego that you
couldn't handle losing 40 or that idea
that someone could trick you so you have
to murder them it's the wrong way to
think about social Modern Life you can't
have like a [__] caveman attitude and
it's like so many people are like
praising like just being like an idiot
and it's like hey uh this is not a alpha
way to function in a modern society and
it's just like nobody's like making that
cool and an alpha way to function in
that response would be to be like that's
actually hilarious I got tricked [__]
and not give a [__] about it to be like
forty dollars doesn't mean anything to
me I can totally brush that off I
[__] don't give a [__] and just move
on to the next thing that would be a
more
[__] a secure response to something
like that rather than feeling the need
to kill someone who tricked you like
what the [__] dude yeah it just shows a
lack of uh knowing who you are who other
people are and it's like you don't care
about anyone else it's yeah it's like
psychopathy yeah no I think it's
completely unhealthy way to think which
I mean I don't know if like social media
and all this stuff people connecting
through that helps or doesn't help with
that but yeah I think it's uh it's a
we're not in a very healthy society
which is good because you know there's a
lot of [__] to make fun of and stuff
yeah it's good for comedy yeah but it's
bad because it's like this is not the
behavior of imagine how much less stress
there'd be if we lived in a society
without had its [__] figured out oh yeah
absolutely it's like being with a
teenager yeah there there was uh there's
some famous study about uh IQ where
there I wish I knew the exact things on
this but it was a village somewhere I
want to say in
um South America where their whole
livelihood is based off of one crop and
they tested people in the village they
tested their IQ before right before the
crop was taken so like when they're at
their poorest like they're like oh [__]
if this crop doesn't come through we're
gonna have nothing all year and right
after the crop was taken to so when
they're at their riches and there was
like an 11 Point difference in IQ
because when you're under that much
stress that Financial stress constantly
on your back it literally makes you
dumber and then they also did tests on
obese kids and they found that obese
kids had a brain that was on average 10
percent smaller then you have people who
are on opioids and all these different
pharmaceutical drugs that are tested
kind of and then they sometimes
someone's on the wrong medication mix
and it [__] with their head and then
you add in a shitty diet high fructose
corn syrup [__] uh too much shitty
carbohydrates pumped into everyone and
then you show them stressful [__] on TV
constantly and then you give them a gun
and it's like yeah of course people are
snapping yeah
yeah it's like we're not taking care of
people until they're going crazy it's
like if you want everyone to get along
yeah then just give them like the basics
to survive like you it's it's not only
like [__] unfair it's not even
efficient yeah a way to have Society
like
yeah I don't know it's just like uh
you're just making people Collide into
each other and
yes uh yeah I I don't know I think uh a
lot of people are like oh I have what I
need I have an iPhone I have a nice
house like why should I ask for more but
it's like how much are you getting
cheated out of yeah it doesn't cost that
much to keep a person alive and you're
working 40 hours a week every week for
the rest of your life and you're not
getting what you deserve you could have
so much more and you're just happy with
what you got like there's someone that's
[__] you and like nobody everyone
knows this and you people don't work
well when they know they're getting
[__] with yeah true people don't like
feeling like that and the people that do
work well are idiots that work well in a
system where they're being exploited
yeah so then you're just rewarding these
brown-nosing idiots who don't really
know what's going on and anyone who is
like aware is punished because of their
awareness so that you're all like
diatribing on Facebook and [__] but
um
I think uh yeah I think if you if you if
you have like a just society and like
people work uh and know they're not
getting exploited too bad then I think
like we could do way better and everyone
would be more at ease and there'd be
less [__] people on the road just
yelling at you and [__] yeah 100 I think
you you start to calm down your
population because they're not they're
like what you said like people getting
[__] out of every corner like I I find
it so irritating how often I have to
like look at labels and then put
something back because there's a whole
bunch of [__] garbage in the food I
was like I can't trust the fruit or I
can't trust the meat how like you
everyone was eating like grass-fed beef
it's like okay that's good and then you
find out that some grass-fed beef is
finished with grains that are all full
of a whole bunch of garbage so then you
need grass finish beef which is even
more expensive and you find out that
like some produce is like overpriced and
they're increasing the price on it just
based on name and like because the like
say if you get something that is like
gluten-free like a gluten-free product
is now more expensive when it was always
gluten-free but they put gluten-free on
the label and then increased the price
because they know they can so they can
[__] you that way it's like how many
[__] ways are you trying to [__] me
every [__] day dude get like say
there's no time to do anything else you
can't like [__] have a small business
and also like you know figure out your
life if you're like growing up in the
ghetto or something exactly if you're
like fighting for each meal and then
you're yeah you're also trying to like
uh get whatever money you can and then
every one of these businesses and like
they're trying to take every dime and
nickel from you and it's like this is
what happens when you have a society
that doesn't care about itself yeah it's
not a functional way to be like that
nobody should be like uh having to fight
off the country that they live in
exactly and like constantly concerned
with how they're getting ripped off like
constantly yeah well that's why like the
guy that got cheated out of forty
dollars like maybe he did have a bad day
he has nothing else he lives with his
mom yeah yeah like you know he works as
an Uber driver so like forty dollars
that's like a big deal to him and like
the outrage of it is like maybe that
maybe anyone in that situation would do
that yeah and it's like you've backed
this guy into a corner where now he's
psychologically fragile and he snaps and
he goes and grabs a gun and shoots a guy
over 40 bucks yeah like uh that Sam
Harris idea that every uh crime can be
predicted like it's just all cause and
effect so like punishing people for the
crime is like you know punishing a
computer program for running a program
that you already knew what was going to
happen yeah so it's like uh why don't we
do that thing where we like you know
predict like what will create a criminal
and then do the opposite of that and
then anyone who does commit a crime
after that then you can like do American
style Justice throw away the keys type
Justice to them because yeah they sort
of deserve it but right now you can't
just like
you know not do any mitigating uh you
know things and then be surprised that
people are committing crimes exactly
like you force people to grow up in a
ghetto and have like no opportunity to
get like uh a property or some sort of
uh health care or anything like that or
even like a decent job uh but you're
like you're well you still got to be
alive and then you're also they're
worried about the violence that's in
their neighborhood so they have to
protect themselves and get guns and get
these different things and then do
things to survive and because they have
no access to a job that will allow them
a livable wage they turn to Crime
because it's the only thing that allows
them to get something where they can
live uh and it's what's everything
around them because that's what the
whole neighborhood has resorted to
because you force these people into that
situation and you go like oh my God like
how could they be doing this
um one of my buddies calls like there's
the the classic like political Playbook
where you like constantly defund
something where you're like you defund
like uh like schools and [__]
whatever uh hospitals communities yeah
Community Center go it's not working
it's again you took away everything that
it needed to work and then you say that
it's not working and what did you do
with that money you put in your [__]
pocket yeah
um I think like uh with the whole school
or the uh
the thing about that
I don't know I was just trying to
remember what I was going to say but I
uh I got a little high and I was also
just changed it's all good man yeah I'm
such a good listener I forget what I
have to say no that's good that's good
do you think that it'll resort to
violence though do you think that we're
eventually just gonna be like burning
down buildings in the street because
that seems like the quickest way to some
sort of result
uh I think that uh we are gonna fizzle
out hopefully
um but yeah I don't think it has to
resort to violence I think it's pretty
uh easy to figure out what we have to do
and I think everyone would be happier if
we just [__] sort of ran ours country
like uh Sim City yeah get AI to do it
but yeah I think what I was going to say
about the gangster thing in the suburbs
is like or the slums is like there is
value in people like human resources and
to not see that value and to pass up on
it it just gives like gangsters the
opportunity to utilize that like there
is such beauty and uh you know like
power in the ghetto and that the gang is
one way to do it like how can they be
extracting wealth I guess exactly
they're they're resourceful these are
smart resourceful people yeah they're
just using the tools that they were
given yeah and it's like you give them a
different opportunity I would I would do
that if I had a choice when I was 22
between being an Uber driver for the
rest of my life or like being a person
in my community that has you know
stature and like you know is respected
yeah like why would I be an Uber driver
like you're making that choice so
unattractive when you look at the it's
the same thing with like the only fans
thing like you if the smarter economics
decision based off like if we remove any
sort of social stigma if you're a girl
fresh out of college uh you have a
degree you're in debt
um you uh your job pays you barely
anything and you can take your shirt off
and make a 10 20 30 maybe even a million
dollars a year like [__] you're
what's the like economically what's the
smart decision to make right now yeah
how how good is that question repression
gonna do yeah exactly and it's like and
we're also going through all these
questions of like what is sexuality what
is like uh whose values are these in
terms of how you can express yourself
sexually is it wrong is it right blah
blah blah
um and but just based off of like an
economic situation it's like it's it's
way smarter to be a a young chick going
only fans make like it's not
unreasonable to be making ten to twenty
thousand dollars a month and build up
your wealth and then buy a piece of
property invest and like keep doing that
and by the time you're 30 you can be
retired rather than working and they go
oh it's degrading or it's [__] wrong
it's like is it more degrading than
working a [__] 40 hour nine to five
that pays you garbage money and that's
what you have to do under these
fluorescent lights forever and you get
fat and sick and all this [__] from
working this job and you give your life
force to some other [__] person who
you never [__] see and doesn't give a
[__] about you if you quit today or they
had to fire you or let you off they
would give you like [__] two months
Severance and then send you off to die
like what is more degrading or is and is
even the only fans thing degrading in
the first place yeah is that just
perception of these like Christian
values outside of our own and might not
I don't know I've never was raised with
religion in like at all maybe it's like
they're like oh you're not doing
anything for society you're not bottling
you know toothpaste up or like you know
you're not hoeing this grass or whatever
but it's like how are those people that
actually contribute to society rewarded
like teach teachers yeah or like you
know public servants like if you're not
going to reward them then why if you're
not going to make that an attractive
option then you're just you're just
haranguing people into doing the right
thing but not you're not doing the right
thing by paying them enough it's like
why don't you do the right thing by
paying them enough or if that's not
going to happen we're just gonna make
money selling butthole picks to each
other exactly it's not only more
profitable but the market has spoken
you've pushed these you've like you're
like what is the more well we're all
basing everything off the market the
market will speak and then people will
respond it's like this is what the
market wants the market wants it a lot
and it's buying a [__] lot and why
don't you think that's only because
we're so [__] up right now that we're
like trying to like find any positive
part of someone by looking at their
buttholes it could be it could be that I
think it's just that uh I think sex work
has always been there sex work is like
it's existed like they call prostitution
I think it's a beautiful thing about
humans is that we love each other's body
so much we'll just stare at it all day
I'm very sex positive I'm very sex
positive in all this stuff through my
content you can definitely see it so I'm
I support anyone who wants to do
whatever they want the [__] they want
with their body I don't give a [__] man
that's your body you can do whatever if
you were like in the middle of World War
II and they were like Nazi planes
bombing us and some chick was just
taking butthole pictures I'd be pissed
off but we're not doing anything no it's
better to do nothing than to help
whatever this is continue doing it but
then also you look at it if we're same
scenario if we're in Nazi Germany we're
getting bombed and then uh some check
comes into the camp shows all the dudes
are tits we would be like yeah like what
a huge morale boost to see those tips
that would [__] bring the boys
together of those two I have yeah I mean
definitely that would definitely help
morale but isn't that funny like that's
all it takes for us to like to feel so
crazy to feel great it's just a pair of
nice tits uh I love it though boobs are
great
um but uh but yeah no I I think the the
you the all of these things are a result
of the last thing it's like we it's so
hard to make money okay well only fans
is going to capitalize on this and then
you're trying to shame these people for
being on only fans it's like but you
like it's that's such a [__] stupid
thing to to put someone in such a
horrible economic situation where they
can't [__] do anything they can't
afford to live they can't afford to get
groceries and you give them an
opportunity to do something with the
tools that they have and they capitalize
on it you go oh you're disgusting you're
less worthy and all this stuff it's like
[__] you for one they're not they're
like it is we're consuming it it's a
[__] equal exchange if you're looking
at the butthole picks or you're looking
at porn and then you say a porn star is
less worthy you're just as bad you're
consuming you're part of the process
dude they're not even having agency in
the process you're like the one that's
the the [__] or the exactly you're the
one paying for it yeah and that's like
the [__] uh it's the Jesus thing the
the him with uh he without sync and cast
the first stone if you've never watched
porn you've never jerked off to any
other like pics or anything then you can
[__] on these girls then if you've been
the purest one of Pura and you've never
[__] done anything then you can come
forward yeah I think a lot of the as men
that are jealous that women are getting
attention like they wish they had a body
that people would want to they could
capitalize on that I think it's
insecurity as well I think the idea
um I think guys fear even though it's
not something that's
necessarily happening to them directly
they fear the idea of being with a woman
who is then doing that and not even how
they would feel about it but how they
would be perceived by other men that is
what they're afraid of that insecurity
of feeling like a [__] so they're just
worried that they're gonna end up with a
girl like that yeah I think that's part
of it or just I don't know trying to
tame it tame the whole gender yes
exactly so they can feel better when
they eventually get a girlfriend yes yes
um and on the [__] Jesus thing I
thought it was really funny when uh Mr
Beast cured people from blindness and
then people got mad at him for it I was
like dude Jesus do the exact same thing
Jesus like cure people's blindness in
this then they [__] staked him to a
cross
like this isn't the most good you could
have done better with something else
yeah it was so that one was [__] wild
that like you cure people's blindness
and they're like oh you're just
profiting off these blind people it's
like oh what the [__] and I just like if
you're if you want to comment that or
tweet that you should have to donate
like a hundred dollars to an
organization before you're allowed to
tweet that you should have to do some
good like he did before you can comment
on people doing like clippy like looks
like you're criticizing someone for not
giving a charity in the right way would
you like to donate yeah exactly like we
we can't tweet this until you donate a
hundred dollars to sick kids Foundation
yeah the hypocrisy is uh off the charts
on this year yeah we can't send this
that would be so funny it's like the
[__] it's like the Black Mirror
episode with like social credit but it's
like a hypocrisy meter like how
hypocritical you're being and you've got
to like maintain your hypocrisy all the
Republican Senators that are grooming
kids yeah they wouldn't be able to
spread their LGBT hate yeah they're like
we can like see the hypocrisy meter
going up as they're trying to uh spew
their [__] oh that would be [__]
great yeah
um yeah I think I think sex work is
amazing
um I enjoy it
um
I uh I think it's like a social thing
too like the art of showing genitals
it's like it's not as easy as people
think it is oh these girls are grinding
man yeah
and that they're like learning about
people and like playing off what they
it's like comedy sort of yeah their
desires they're finding out like like
what video is gonna go viral what hits
what's my Niche what what it like what
do I have to change my personality yeah
exactly too like appeal to the fans and
everything like that and the the what
they're doing like you know you know
Adriana chechik right I don't
she's a she's like one of the best of
all time like by far in terms of porn
she's like uh has done some of the
craziest scenes and she's like I think
of myself as an athlete because what she
does with her body is crazy like for one
she has to be in shape constantly but
she has like all these wild injuries she
had like her brain stem was coming out a
little bit in her spine because she gets
[__] in pile drivers so much and she
did like a triple anal like wild [__]
and porn she did yeah um which is like
yeah you're you're not that's not an
easy day at the office to get Triple
analed I know especially with the so
after vagina yeah soft your vagina's
right there and the ass isn't made to be
triple Five Oh you mean oh the ass yeah
it was three it was three yeah your
holes yeah holes hurt
that would suck oh yeah after a long day
dude my holes are never in pain I can't
even I would be like I know but maybe
it's it's maybe she likes it maybe she
likes it in pain
uh
it's a good reminder I don't know uh but
yeah I think uh girls
she got her brainstem blown out some guy
in the chat
um but yeah I think uh it's it's as good
as any job I don't really respect jobs
that much I think people that have this
idea of jobs as an official like this is
what you know George W bush wanted me to
do today dude you would you and one of
my buddies I could stream with this guy
Cameron you would you guys would get
along a lot he [__] he always says
he's like [__] jobs because he talks
about like how they're like Ai and these
automatic cars they're gonna take jobs
he's like yeah good take all the jobs
why are we doing jobs jobs suck yeah we
shouldn't the goal shouldn't be oh I'm
working I have a job it should be to get
away from work that should be our goal
to [__] hang out and walk around on
the [__] beach and like uh drink a
martini whatever like to start a fire
hang out with your friends it's
brainwashing they want us to enjoy work
so that we'll keep doing it for free
like you look like Europeans hanging out
and drinking espresso with their friends
and like [__] having a glass of wine
in the middle of the day and just like
you're chilling out it's like that's
[__] each week I'm not saying what
they're doing over there perfect but we
should be closer to that we shouldn't be
moving further away where it's like
you've got to be working the 12-hour day
I've been working 18 hour days for five
years it's like what the [__] that's not
good that's not a good way to spend your
[__] life doing it it should be like
this podcasting yeah something like
going around doing [__] comp like
when you're when I do spots all night
it's [__] great I bounce from show to
show to show you hang out with everybody
doing something yeah you write a new
joke you try it out you feel [__]
great from it you you talk [__] with
your friends you have a [__] tequila
soda and then you you I don't know a
slice of life is like misery and they're
like I'm good at being miserable and
that's the only skill that you should
test for oh dude that's [__] horrible
like have you worked on office job a
little bit it's [__] trash like the
best part of the office job is the
people in the office your brain just
[__] shriveling yeah it's like no
stimulation you can't have outbursts
you're just stuck in this little Pasty
pastel colored building is worse the
colors are some of the worst [__]
parts of it I grew up in the suburbs and
that's like my least favorite [__]
part of that of that [__] the The Office
Buildings that like weird gray brown
beige that's on [__] everything it
just it's such a shitty look it looks
just like where Dreams Come To Die like
mediocrity embodied in construction it
[__] looks horrible I hate it yeah
and to some people it's Comfort they're
like ah finally no horrible colors and
no no thoughts yeah no expression no
individuality no uh oatmeal of buildings
yeah oh exactly that's [__] the best
way to put it the oatmeal of building
yeah it's just gonna kill any sort of
stimulation it's just gonna make you
[__] dead and uh yeah they're trying
to neuter you yeah neuter exactly they
are trying to nude you're like new to
your spirit yeah that's why like there's
the city is great because it's like so
much competition so much interaction so
much motivation the people go there with
dreams people go there to [__] get
things done and to meet new people and
to experience new things and different
food different music different
Lifestyles like that's what the city is
great for but then also on the other end
when you have like country living like
in the middle of nowhere there's more of
a sense of community you know your
neighbors you say good morning to people
there's a you you care about people when
you know all the people you live around
and there's obviously downsides to
either side there can be like too much
anonymity in the city and sometimes you
can feel very alone even with all those
people around you and then you can also
have like no anonymity in the country
and having everyone in your business but
in the middle when you get to the
suburbs it's like nothing it's like high
school never died all these people that
are like bitching about you and [__]
talking about you behind your back yeah
you're not colliding into each other
you're like if you want to meet someone
you have to make an effort and it's like
there's no natural organic meetings
anymore no you like live in your box
your little box that's on your little
box lot and then you drive to your box
and you do your things in your box and
then you're not allowed to leave your
box and talk to your neighbor or else
you get in trouble and then you drive
back to this other box where it's like
[__] it's Costco and it's all that
[__] and you're doing all the [__] there
and you don't talk to the people there
you don't strike up random conversations
because you would be considered weird
and be a social faux pas where it's like
you you don't have that in the other on
the other ends of the spectrum that
middle [__] milk toast whatever the
[__] it is in the middle it it it's
horrible
yeah
but yeah sorry that was a long rant no I
don't like the suburbs basically at the
end of the day like you don't get any
any of the positives or the negatives of
either or you get only the negatives of
of each side and you oh with a false
sense of security is what you get out of
it it's like people it's just like
living in some weird fear of what your
neighbors are doing or what could
possibly happen to you of what how much
money you're gonna make and just like
[__] rotting just rotting
yeah anything creative or good about you
is abandoned in the middle of a giant
lot like yeah you can't express yourself
or impact anyone and we need each other
and these people don't have anyone yeah
and you would exhaust yourself for some
organization that doesn't give two shits
about you and then when you get home you
have no energy left to do anything
that's like substantial or motivating or
inspiring and so you spend that time I
don't know like [__] scrolling on the
Internet or watching Big Bang Theory or
filling the void with something so you
can just like turn your brain off for a
moment and have some peace before you
gotta go back yeah that's horrible yeah
that's that's the life that most of us
most of the people live actually yeah no
and it's not exciting it's not exciting
to live
I wonder if
it's a little glitchy I think are we
getting uh
are we a little glitchy or we are a
little glitched out
oh well maybe it's more audio
I tried this new setting
are they what's the chat saying are they
they were saying it was glitchy and then
I sort of ignored them
yeah I know I do that with the chat all
the time
you're like you're like uh we'll see you
guys let us know in a moment if it's
still like that
yeah anyways
um I mean I think it's uh
pretty crazy
the whole thing but uh yeah I mean
I think it's good that uh you know I'm
sold out to do whatever the [__] this is
yeah no you it's good to feel like
you've escaped it you're you're outside
that
bubble of I don't know
constant dredge and you can focus on
other things like I I like I said I've
never ever tried to chase money that's
never been the focus the focus has
always been like have fun first enjoy
your life first and that's evolved as
I've gotten older like yeah it's like
when I was younger it's like maybe like
party and drink a little bit too much
and it's like now it's like who are my
real friends spend more time with your
friends spend more time with your family
build honest connections with people
um like yep still stand up always
brought me joy video games always
brought me joy like [__] Fitness
these things make sure these are like
baselines of your life and you can as
long as those things are constantly in
your life you'll you'll feel happy
everything else around that noise and uh
yeah I've always been very simplistic
with how I view things um like they're
just follow your bliss yeah follow your
bliss I feel like a lot of people get
caught up in things that uh seem
exciting or or beneficial but it's
really like just a sophisticated glaze
uh poured over something that's like
boring and
so interesting to see what other people
occupy their lives with like what kind
of MLM schemes that they're into and
what they think a real life is it's like
oh I can see from what you're interested
in that you might actually be into like
surfing or something real yes that
people are actually into yeah and gives
you like some sort of sense of of growth
and exercise and and stability in red
tactile stuff splashing in the water
falling off your board like being alive
and present uh I look at something like
really really fancy restaurants like you
spend like thousands of dollars for like
a meal and they do some weird [__] and
you eat it and you're like okay is it it
maybe it's really good or maybe it's
it's good but then if you go to like
some sandwich shop on [__] a Sixth
Street and you're like yo this place is
[__] bomb and it's just some [__]
little greasy Diner or some [__]
burger place or whatever and you're like
oh this place rules it's like why did we
need to put this giant [__] glaze of
importance on this thing then make it
seem like it was grandiose when it's
like you get the same experience that's
maybe better somewhere else like uh one
of my buddies and he's very [__]
right about this we would go up to his
Cottage and there was like 10 of us
we're all Comics we would go up there
we'd do mushrooms we'd go on Hikes and
then we would just like laugh and shoot
the [__] and it was we do that for like
four days and it's so [__] fun it's
so fun uh and that whole weekend
probably cost like 200 and there's not I
spent a lot of money on a lot of
different things and gone tried
different stuff and you go to [__]
Disneyland or you go to [__] wherever
you buy get tickets do a thing on New
Year's Eve and go to a club and uh
there's a I don't I don't know if I can
think of a thing that amounts to as much
fun and as much like connection and
memories as as like spending the weekend
at that Cottage and this is a little
[__] Cottage where the toilet doesn't
work we had to ride bikes down to the
beach because there was a toilet like a
toilet there that we would go take shits
in like that's that and that is what I
think people lose sight of and lose
connection to is what are these what is
actually bringing you Joy not with
someone else told you supposed to bring
you Joy not what is perceived as like
special or important or sophisticated
what is actually they good they cut us
off from our own ability to figure out
what we like yeah I think with school
and circumcision and a lot of different
stuff yeah but yeah I mean I think like
once you lose that connection to what
brings you Joy and you're totally
relying on this system the society to
fill that in for you like oh this will
bring you Joy then you're like you know
you're almost irredeemably lost because
then you can just be filled in with
whatever desire that other people want
you to have I think that's a big part
that comedy helps you figure out because
in order to get good at stand up they
have like whatever like finding your
voices in quotations right it's really
just defining your sense of humor it's
like what do I really really find funny
and when you have like a when you're
really in tuned with what you find funny
you like every movie I watch show I
watch experience I have how I talk to
people all of that can go through the
filter of what I find funny and I have a
really good sense of what I like and
from there you start to span off into
what other things you're like okay well
I understand what it feels like to truly
enjoy something funny okay what does it
mean to truly enjoy food what does it
mean to truly enjoy exercise and all
these things what are these experience
that I want like in the moment feel in
my body and I can cut out the noise
around it like I can work out better I
can eat better I can sleep better I can
have better relationships with my
friends and family because I have
defined this thing in my life so
intimately yeah
yeah once you get the center correct
your foundation then everything else is
easier yeah that's like the show Barry's
about it's like the same thing but with
acting like what are you feeling if you
can't be honest with what you're feeling
right now then there's no basis to jump
off of
then you're just
um
faking a fake emotion then it's like
yeah it's better to know who you are and
get all that [__] figured out so you
know what anger or sadness feels like
coming through you authentically you can
mimic it later yeah but yeah and be like
honest with yourself really honest with
yourself yeah that's like I think hard
for a lot of people to do to really feel
honest and it comes through and all
these different things you it comes
through like sexuality people lying
about who they find attractive or what
they find attractive or like
relationships or yeah a status in Life
or how you want to live and like people
start putting all these things in front
of them that they think they should have
based on what other people are going to
perceive of them rather than being like
this is how I want to live some people
want to go [__] live in the woods in
a [__] hammock but they're like oh
but if I do that everyone's gonna think
I'm poor weird or blah blah it's like
just go [__] do it dude you're gonna
be so unhappy not doing it don't be
afraid yeah don't don't try to live the
life that everyone else is living we
already know how that turns out we don't
need more data points in that direction
yeah yeah
um it's 6 24. did you said you had to go
I do have another podcast I got to do it
at uh at 6 45 so yes okay awesome well
thanks for doing the podcast dude thank
you man this has been great yeah thanks
for coming around yeah no I had a good
time I I'll do a quick plug I didn't
even say my name I'm Jade Arena I'm you
can catch me on all platforms at Jade
Arena c-h-e-d-o-r-e-n-a on Twitch and
kick at little dinky news and
chadarena.com for all tour dates I'm
going to be in Oklahoma in July and
Austin in September uh and then Raleigh
also in September uh and that's all
awesome thanks man thanks for coming
thanks I appreciate man yeah